collider that sounds like a new movie
that's starring Dwayne The Rock Johnson
in Collider
listen I will be happy I'll be happy if
he makes that movie
Dwayne Johnson running away from a ball
of fire and then explodes and he throws
himself forward and lands off camera
Dwayne Johnson in Kalida with Tom Hanks
is a man called Autumn uh that's great
uh I just want to start with not being
serious that's great I love that um good
movie actually let's book it let's book
it yeah exactly um as I've said to you
every time I've been lucky enough to
talk to you I want to thank you for
giving me your time I'm a huge fan of
your work
um but today is a special day because
I'm actually in Brazil right now at the
biggest Comic-Con in Latin America and
one of the biggest in the world and I
wanted to show it to you because uh you
can hopefully see it's there's about a
yeah I know you're looking at a small
screen yeah you can kind of see it
yeah so everyone at ccxp wanted me to
invite you down here at some point uh
they want you here so they wanted me to
show you the backdrop hey do me a favor
pick up some swag bring me some give me
some book bags and some shirts you know
some promotional materials
um you know I don't know uh the that
looks like everybody in Latin America is
at this uh uh Comic-Con that you have
what's crazy is that all the studios are
here as you can see
um and right now you can see this is a
live stage that they want you on at some
point who's up there right now uh right
now it's Rodrigo Santoro who's a big
Brazilian actor and the cast of Dungeons
and Dragons is about to come out oh my
Lord Dungeons and Dragons is about to go
now is that a better Comic-Con than is
in say San Diego or Jakarta or uh it's a
little you know something this is a very
impressive Comic-Con but it's a it's
different than San Diego but the energy
down here is is crazy it's really you
can see but enough about I just wanted
to present it to you okay all right
there you go um but you know something
um I I'm so curious you obviously get
offered so many scripts and everyone
wants to work with you so what was it
about this project that said like I want
to give it my time and my six months of
my life or whatever it was to make the
movie these things happen uh that uh uh
a possibility comes comes along about
eight years prior
uh we saw my wife and I my the readers
my Rita Wilson is the true producer of
this movie
um we saw the original Swedish movie
when it first came out in 2016.
from the moment that we first saw we
both felt that there was this American
ideal version of it that
needed to be brought forward because the
human condition requires belonging to a
community and in the United States it is
very easy to become so insular and so
alone and so singular that you might not
be able to agree with enough people in
order to belong to a community
particularly when somebody moves across
the street that is very different from
you we thought that was a germ of a of
an idea that could really be explored by
in the guise of this incredibly cranky
guy now the novel by Frederick Bachmann
as well as the original movie are both
masterpieces so he figured out well why
you know why bother trying to try to
come up with a different version of it
and the at the answer was because I
think what it it is universal The Human
Condition is what not and what the the
the
Otto Anderson goes through is that that
fascinating mix between what he wants to
avoid avoid and what he absolutely has
to have he does not want a bunch of
Mexicans moving across the street from
him but when they do it's the best thing
that could ever happen to him because it
draws him into a much greater life than
than he would have had that's a big
theme to deal with man it's it's as big
as anything that the Greeks could ever
come up come up to and you know if I was
going to say you know uh you know the
there there are any number of
superheroes literally from the Comic-Con
thing that experience that same exact
guy how many lone lone people you know
are so fixed in their ways and yet it's
not until they go out into the greater
bigger world that their life becomes uh
larger than it should be so it doesn't
it it's not like you read a script and
say oh I want to make this in six six
months we actually saw this movie six
years ago and we said we'd like to be
able to turn this into a movie if we
could find like-minded allies and we did
uh I love cats and one of the and I want
to know as someone who loves cats do you
think one of the morals of this movie is
a cat can help save your life absolutely
as long as your wife is not allergic to
him I think a cat makes your life a
better thing because
um you have to win them over but when
you do
they add a great quality to your life
that never ever goes away as long as
they they stay with you I happen cats
crack me up and uh I I wish I wish we
could have some but and that individual
Cat by the way there's only one way to
work with a cat in a movie and that is
to make that cat
smell you like you sit with you look at
you be involved with you not an easy
thing to do but we had a good cat uh I
could tell when I was watching or you
just did it a thousand times until you
got it well actually there was there was
a there's one there's one thing at the
end where the cat and I just stayed in
each other's arms for you know the
better part of the afternoon I think we
were both very happy uh you have done so
many impressive roles throughout your
career and I'm I'm curious about the
behind the scenes of making movies so
would you mind sharing with me the shot
or sequence from your career that ended
up you think being what the hardest or
one of the hardest shots to pull off
if you saw a movie called Turner and
Hooch I did right yep the scene where I
first get that dog
in a collar in a car or attached to a
car
um and off to the first time that it it
was
I'll just go back and look at it it uh
it was the most physical exhausting
time-consuming thing and because it
could only happen in the real world this
is not a moment of CGI to it there's not
a moment of stunt man being involved in
it it was just me and Beasley who was
the dog who was playing Hooch at the
time and it was uh it was
steadicams uh multiple multiple versions
of it and the thing that was exhausting
about it was
it was just me and that dog every step
of the way it happened in real time and
it happened over like a number of hours
and my body was beaten to a pulp by the
time we got to then and it was also full
energy the entire time I had to be
petrified of this dog at the same time I
was commanding that dog I don't know why
what year did we make that movie I'll
tell you it was 33 years ago and that I
can still have I still have tactile
memories of how hard that that shot was
to get on that note sir I need to wrap
I'm just going to say thank you so much
for giving me your time and everyone
wants me to tell you please come to
Brazil on my way